if you've been on the Internet any time
in the past couple of weeks you've
probably seen this it's a fish zooming
through a tube going over a dam and then
flying out the other side it's known as
the salmon cannon and it has not
surprisingly sparked a lot of jokes and
memes online and not even for the first
time back in 2014 John Oliver took the
cannon to its most absurd extreme by
using it to assault celebrities with
flying fish and while it seems like a
really fun kind of waterslide the salmon
cannon is actually designed to address a
pretty challenging problem how do you
move fish from one side of a dam to
another to find out more about this
unconventional looking means of fish
transport we spoke with a fisheries
researcher at the Pacific Northwest
National Laboratory my name is Allison
Kola hello and I'm a research scientist
and project manager here at Pacific
Northwest National Lab a lot of the work
that I do revolves around how hydropower
impacts fish populations
so obviously the salmon cannon has
garnered a lot of attention on social
media mostly because it looks kind of
silly but it serves a really important
function right so what what is that
function the salmon cannon or the woosh
fish transport system is a relatively
new technology that's been developed to
move fish around barriers like
hydroelectric dams hydropower is one of
our most important renewable resources
but it also creates a blockade or a
barrier fish have different life
histories so they're going to different
habitats throughout their life because
of different critical steps as they
develop salmon they need to go to the
ocean and return American shad on the
east coast of the United States they
also have a large migration to the ocean
and back during their life American eels
are also something that is really
popular in the news right now they're
actually the opposite of salmon and
they're born in the ocean come to
freshwater and then they return to the
ocean to spawn they need these fish ways
to be able to pass safely through
barriers and be able to return to their
spawning grounds how does the salmon
cannon work both from sort of a
practical standpoint and then just
mechanistically you what we've seen
going viral
in some of the videos
online recently has been somebody
actually hand loading the fish into it
into the accelerator or that cannon part
of it there is a newer version of the
technology that pnnl evaluated in 2017
where the fish are able to swim up a
similar to a fish ladder a fish wave and
enter into that into that accelerator
system more volitionally so without
being hand loaded into it once the fish
swim up that fish way they enter into
this chamber where there's a series of
cameras that take pictures from lots of
different angles and they have some
computer algorithms that assess the size
of the fish and then in split seconds
less than a second they route fish to
the different tubes based on how big
those fish are big fish go to the big
tube the little fish go to the little
tube but once the fish gets into that
tube there's kind of a tight seal formed
around the fish the inside of the tube
is lightly misted with water so it has a
lubrication associated with it they add
some air from behind a blower which
pushes the fish gently through the tube
kind of like when you go to the bank and
they send the checks inside prior to the
advent of the salmon cannon what are the
other major categories of fish transport
what are the alternatives I think the
one that most people will recognize is
fish otters they have different designs
but generally they're kind of pools that
the fish are jumping into and swimming
through we also have fish elevators
where fish will swim into a funnel area
kind of like a bucket and then they're
essentially hoisted and dumped on the
other side of the barrier we also have
climbing ramps for things like eels and
lamprey that tend to like less water but
structure that they can grab onto and
then trap and haul where fish are kind
of funneled corralled and loaded into a
truck and then they're driven around a
barrier if this thing is a cannon
artillery sounds kind of dangerous
it's do we have any sense of whether
this is harmful to the fish in any way
in 2014 we looked really closely at the
external injuries to the fish and we
used a chemical called flow
seem to look at that that's a chemical
that's often used in crime scene
investigations to look for latent traces
of blood fish are coated in a thin layer
of epithelial cells so very similar to
our eyes or our mouth anywhere where
we're producing mucus essentially if
there's any damage to that there'd be
blood
not necessarily in volumes that we would
be able to visually see so fluorescein
is really helpful in looking for those
latent things things that we're not able
to detect with the human eye we also
looked for any large macroscopic injury
so anything that we could visually
detect and we looked at effects on the
reproduction of those fish and we looked
at their stress levels all of those were
comparable in 2014 to trackin home it
wasn't that it was non-existent but it
was comparable to the way that we
commonly moved fish it sounds like there
are multiple ways to ask the question
does this hurt the fish right they're
sort of they're sort of physical harm
there is sort of reproductive harm
that's related to their overall fitness
right and in fecundity as a species so
it's it's a complex question right it's
not as simple as like oh they're coming
out the other side okay
yeah that's an absolutely good point so
looking at physical damage looking at
reproductive health also looking at
stress levels which can lead to long
term issues or delayed death as a result
of passing through any kind of passage
system we only looked at this short term
effect so fish moving through the tube
what was happening in a few hours or a
couple days after their passage through
the system but there is definitely a
need to look at it from a longer
perspective and there's multitudes of
studies that could be done to follow up
on that what makes fish transport such a
big challenge I think part of the
challenge is that we have close to
30,000 species of fish globally and all
of those fish have very different
characteristics they have different
swimming abilities different sizes
different life history patterns so
they're going to different habitats at
different times so one size might not
fit all I think that's the biggest
challenge is trying to find something
that can incorporate that variability in
the different species of fish that we
have but also something
that will work effectively and is
cost-effective that sort of leads into
the next question which is why aren't
there more salmon cannons or why don't
we see them in more places whenever we
have new technologies we want to make
sure that we're not impacting the
resource that they might be interacting
with and so there's a need for
additional studies to really evaluate
this and they just take a long time to
do so innovation can't move quickly
sometimes well thank you so much for
talking with us thank you very much